y
[Música]
una persona falleció en medio de los
disturbios ocurridos en colombia en la
jornada de masivas manifestaciones en
rechazo a la reforma fiscal que propone
el presidente iván duque estos hechos
tienen lugar en medio del tercer pico de
la pandemia de kobe 19 que hoy dejó la
cifra récord de 490 muertos tenemos
reporte desde bogotá la capital
colombiana
el presidente de eeuu yobái tendrá un
esperado discurso ante el pleno de las
dos cámaras del congreso con motivo de
sus primeros 100 días de mandato se
espera que el mandatario hable sobre el
avance de la vacunación estímulo
económico migración y los recortes
fiscales a los más privilegiados
económicamente
india el nuevo foco de la pandemia de
kobe 19 a nivel mundial sigue
enfrentando el colapso hospitalario la
falta de oxígeno y la saturación de los
servicios funerarios 201 mil personas
han fallecido mientras que un promedio
de 300.000 personas han sido contagiadas
diariamente según el conteo de esta
semana la situación se agrava debido al
rápido avance de la variante india
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález jornada de manifestaciones
ciudadanas en colombia en rechazo por la
reforma fiscal y las políticas
económicas impuestas por el presidente y
bando que una persona murió en la ciudad
de cali ciudad en donde se presentaron
varios disturbios saqueos y también
actos vandálicos que llevaron a las
autoridades locales a decretar el inicio
del toque de queda a las 3 de la tarde
para mitigar el impacto de estas marchas
en otras ciudades como bogotá las
manifestaciones contaron con una alta
participación pero se desarrollaron con
algunos enfrentamientos con las
autoridades como los ocurridos
justamente frente a las instalaciones de
un canal de televisión local que fue
atacado por varios manifestantes esto
tiene lugar cuando colombia atraviesa
uno de los peores momentos de la
pandemia de kobe 19 luís muñoz
periodista de france 24 siguió estas
marchas en las calles de bogotá y nos da
más detalles en su reporte
colombia ha vivido este miércoles 28 de
abril una jornada de paro nacional en
sus principales ciudades los
manifestantes han salido por distintos
motivos pero el principal ha sido la
nueva reforma tributaria que plantea el
gobierno de iván duque y que este
manifestante a continuación nos explica
más en qué consiste
los ciudadanos están marchando porque la
gran mayoría de ellos se sienten
defraudados con el gobierno por la nueva
reforma tributaria que está haciendo
tránsito en el congreso de la república
donde se están grabando muchos productos
entre esos dos de la canasta familiar
colombia vive su tercera ola de la
pandemia y está siendo la más crítica de
hecho el país está registrando más de
400 muertes diarias en la última semana
y además las principales ciudades tienen
las ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos por encima del 90
por ciento sin embargo como nos cuenta
esta manifestante el co 19 no ha sido
una excusa para no salir a marchar nos
parece también que que pues es necesario
hacer esto porque ellos siempre hacen lo
que quieren la reforma tributaria
básicamente nos va a incrementar a
nosotros los costos de la canasta
cuando ni siquiera tenemos trabajo y ni
siquiera tenemos dinero ya casi para
comer yo vivo al día casi que me van a
echar de la casa porque no tenía cómo
pagar y pues aquí ciudad que me gusta
riendo a pesar de los constantes
llamados para no marchar miles de
colombianos han salido por todo el país
aquí en bogotá por ejemplo ha habido
choques entre manifestantes y policía
también ha habido llamados de la
alcaldesa de bogotá para que los
colombianos los bogotanos regresen a las
2 de la tarde algo que no se ha
obedecido pero donde parece que habido
más intensidad en los enfrentamientos ha
sido en cali la primera hora de la
mañana el grupo indígena misak ha
tumbado una estatua del conquistador
español sebastián belalcázar y más tarde
a la una de la tarde se ha tenido que
decretar un toque de queda que durará
hasta el domingo hechos que demuestran
la grave situación y el enfado que viven
los colombianos
yo vaivén cumplirá 100 días como
presidente de eeuu el próximo viernes el
mandatario dará un esperado discurso en
la noche de hoy ante ambas cámaras del
congreso en dicho discurso se espera que
hable sobre el avance que ha tenido la
vacunación los planes de estímulo
económico migración y también que
solicite apoyo para avanzar con su plan
de bienestar social y también ayuda para
instaurar los recortes fiscales a los
más privilegiados económicamente alva
santana tiene los detalles con más
vacunas aplicadas que en cualquier otro
país el presidente yo vaivén llega a sus
100 días en la presidencia con una
promesa cumplida más de 230 millones de
dósis inoculadas y un 29 por ciento de
la población totalmente inmunizada el
tapabocas ya no es necesario al aire
libre para los inmunizados guardia y
quiero ser totalmente claro si estás en
una aglomeración como en un estadio en
una conferencia o en un concierto
todavía debes usar el tapabocas where
amas el partido de baile en el demócrata
presentó una protesta de reforma a la
policía en el congreso que ya tiene el
visto bueno de la cámara de
representantes pero aún enfrenta el
desafío del senado el mandatario exhortó
a los legisladores a probarla tras la
condena al ex policía derecho ven por el
asesinato del afroamericano georg floyd
by den tiene el gran reto de la ola
migratoria proveniente de centroamérica
de enero a marzo se ha registrado un
aumento de 100.000 detenidos en la
frontera algo que le ha costado críticas
de los republicanos pero para atenderlo
la vicepresidenta kamala harris anunció
una ayuda de 310 millones a centro
no obstante presentó una reforma
migratoria al congreso que propone un
camino a la ciudadanía para los 11
millones de indocumentados que se estima
hay en eeuu también debe ser negociada
con los republicanos en el / senado
además de cumplir con la promesa del
plan de estímulo de 19 billones de
dólares
bailén ha aumentado el salario mínimo de
725 a 15 dólares la hora el presidente
regresó a eeuu al acuerdo climático de
parís y retomó las negociaciones sobre
el pacto nuclear con irán además ha
fijado a china y rúsia como sus grandes
adversarios internacionales aplicando
sanciones contra el último por un
supuesto ciberataque y el envenenamiento
al opositor al ex sin avales a las 8 de
la noche hora de bogotá france 24
transmitirá en directo este discurso del
presidente de eeuu joe biden con motivo
de sus primeros 100 días en el cargo
analizaremos los puntos más destacados
de este discurso los esperamos
cambiamos de tema las autoridades de
francia arrestaron a pedido de italia a
7 antiguo integrantes de diferentes
grupos radicales italianos la mayoría de
ellos de las llamadas brigadas rojas
otras tres personas más son buscadas por
las autoridades francesas para luego ser
deportadas a italia
harlin foster líder del partido
unionista democrático y ministra
principal de irlanda del norte dimitió
del cargo ante las críticas al interior
de su formación política y la tensión
que ha generado el break city foster se
adelantó hacia una posible moción de
censura impulsada por sus propios
diputados que evidencian el descontento
de los ciudadanos y de los partidos
políticos norirlandeses por la posición
en la que quedó este país después del
prsc
en otros temas india sigue haciendo
frente a la crítica situación provocada
por el pico de contagio de kobe 19 unas
300.000 personas han sido diagnosticadas
diariamente con el coronavirus en la
última semana esto mientras el colapso
del sistema de salud de los servicios
funerarios y también de la falta de
oxígeno ya elevaron la cifra de
fallecidos a 201 mil personas la
situación empeora debido al avance
también de la variante de india que
según la oms está presente ya en 17
países
andrew amaya nos cuenta más
y cientos de cuerpos son incinerados
masivamente los crematorios no dan
abasto ante la avalancha de muertes por
kobe 19 en india muchos de los
familiares lamentan no haber tenido un
último contacto con sus seres queridos y
critican la asistencia médica limitada
hasta ayer estaba sentada fuera del
hospital y me decían que mi esposo
estaba bien les pedí que me dejaran
verlo por última vez e incluso les
ofreció dinero para que me dejaran estar
con él ahora está muerto estoy tan
molesta no hay nada que yo pueda hacer
[Música]
la emergencia sanitaria también se
siente con la falta de oxígeno la oleada
de contagios en india ha hecho que
encontrar y llevar suministros a los
enfermos sea todo un reto fuera de la
tienda más de un centenar de personas ha
hecho fila con la esperanza de que quede
suficiente para llenar sus botellas
formamos es para mi tío tiene 75 años de
una condición crítica comparativa antes
de la oleada de kobe el propietario de
la tienda vendió oxígeno líquido a
empresas de construcción pero eso era
antes tan vargas en este momento
realmente no es suficiente sólo tengo
suficiente para la mitad de las
solicitudes los hospitales están
desbordados en todo el país algunos
reaccionan lo que les queda bajando los
niveles de los respiradores el gobierno
dice que puede producir 7 mil 200
toneladas al día pero la necesidad
diaria con el coronavirus es de 8 mil
toneladas india tiene reservas de 55 mil
toneladas pero la distribución sigue
siendo un reto varios países como españa
reino unido y francia anunciaron que
proporcionarán tres fábricas de oxígeno
móviles capaces de producir 1.500 litros
de oxígeno
nueva delhi ha intentado tranquilizar a
la población diciendo que pronto
llegarán más suministros médicos y más
ayuda internacional es todo por el
momento aquí en las noticias de france
24 más información en france 24 punto
com en las redes sociales y en la app
siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]